ha didn't see you there oh hi my name is
Greg my name is Dan I'm staring at you
yeah uh-uh-uh-uh-uh
dan from that cyber channel my gaming
buddy from another mother playing
overwatch Channel has released overwatch
animated short hero I've been in a
request over the months for like any one
of these that comes out I only saw the
cinematic trailer many months ago with
Dan Dan's been busy um he's been you
know he's been fighting demons fighting
demons
aka my inner demons yeah but it's it's
pretty cool actually you know the cross
this is the only one I haven't seen yet
I saw the other ones I played the beta
boy I need to see the other ones living
home okay good because I want to be like
super confused no I mean it's
highlighting a specific character in
this one this is soldier 76 I believe is
his name
I'm confident on soldier not confident
about the number of I'm pretty sure at
76 he was one of my go-to s in the beta
he's looked like the most hate to say it
like Generic he's the most liked if
you're starting the game off he's the
easiest to get into it cuz it's like
assault rifle and running yeah special
abilities but I'm planning on picking up
this week
money is a thing that sucks hey yeah hey
yeah yeah no yeah I might have my
electronic cigarette with me today cuz
this is a six minute 42 if I get a new
beer use of tobacco this is e-cigarette
I was cool
do not wise so strip looks like a pig
start I know it's so good I'm not a baby
anymore mama stop treating me like one
listen to me mija get the flower and get
back quickly
come on me I get it the struggles real
you worry about that Andra every day no
longer a child
nowhere near grown up she just needs
space wounds punishment bothers me we
tell her about the heroes who saved our
world
time and time again because give her
hope she's losing hope Nationals
rendering games should be forced to make
a choice that will decide the direction
of her life hey hey hey where you going
girl no nowhere nowhere is right come
here you gotta see this oh yeah yeah
look at this thing even what he deserves
Hey
oh I gotta go
robe is Stewart it's just a bucket of
balls ah it's true has no soul
yeah but look at the like that's a
sadist robotic procedures Wow Wow real
big men wow this is a really big med was
abusive she's gonna get her money
she's clutter yo go check that out
hey come on oppa get up
whoa what the hell that's gonna come
well you see and II don't know how
there's black lights around update bevel
come on in fight yes
I'm a holy [ __ ]
my favorite moves bar you Bingham and
nipple chills right now Eddie
let's go you don't get off daddy's dick
kid ah nothing Earl
he was contemplated for nothing okay
he's fast that was literally a second
before like not even a second he was
clearly staring at the time I went off
yes
damn you saved me yeah you're welcome
why
old habits die hard I guess oh man
whistles kid it's a fun heater nice
how'd she have you having no becos
record for house watching the hold on
kill yourself dude not anymore
[ __ ] you're gonna come here oh yeah
and then he proceeds to behave for seeds
to annihilate more bad guys and then
there are the times when I see her smile
and they hope in her eyes and I think
maybe I don't need to worry about that
laughter
do the bat work of blood loss yeah you
really do gotta be concerned burger
coming to PC and consoles May 24th nice
which as of the recording of this is
tomorrow yeah I should put this up
that's pretty sweet
that was pretty sweet although that girl
is I mean I just don't believe she would
walk away like my mom like know that
that's this is awesome violent shake
yeah she always got exploded
Yama's got euros got killed she just had
a life change near-death experience she
did nothing really observe all the best
take it in and realize oh [ __ ] you know
tomorrow she's gonna wake up and not be
able to go walk those fees anymore you
know this kind of reminds me of Watchmen
in terms of how there was like a group
of heroes at the world respected and
then they've all kind of gone away but
now that it looks like we're gonna come
back
you know how the gameplay is gonna be at
all like you get to choose between like
a bunch of different characters you can
play yeah so in the beta they had I
think they had all the characters you
just unlock by playing the game for
maybe like five minutes and you get them
all soldier seventy six six is one of
the first heroes you start off with at
least in the beta the full game is out
basically now you know I have to get my
hands on a full game before I know like
exactly but pretty much every hero you
see and villain in these like short
thing because when we watch cinematic
there was the gorilla tracer the girl
with Widowmaker and then the deaf guy
all four of them a playable characters
which is funny because you see them
fighting each other and like that
cinematic thing and they could just be
on the same team then yeah okay okay
cool let's just take place like around
the world and [ __ ] yeah all the maps are
based off of like countries and stuff
the one weird thing is though is that
there's no campaign mode so you have
like these really beautiful cinematic
things like these cinematic like oh my
God look how cool the story is and then
you get to the gameplay in a small type
like yeah it's like ha I mean how do you
I don't know how the story tellings
really gotta work out how he's fit in ah
as far as you know cinematic masterpiece
they just can't expressly that was
pretty cool six minutes short that was
heading out
don't be giving kids hope and all that
uh yeah I like how heroes nowadays all
sound like that big all sound gruff
everyone has to be this grill I'm the
hero yeah that you need what was the
thing with a robot why were they beating
that robot so um are they beating
chappie there's this sort of tension
between like because robots are
basically functioning free will people
in society and so there's this kind of
tension of like oh we treat them as
equals now but they're soulless and you
know racist sort of things except
towards robots do we know why turn out
that way I mean if I go back and maybe
watch the cinematic things a couple
times you can figure out why but I
haven't died I am a dove too much into
the lore yeah of overwatch but for my
understanding there is tension between
you know robot race and human race and
all that fun jazz I don't know what it
is today
maybe it's because ever since I said
goodbye to Ryan Wright mm-hmm I really
want to make some sex jokes right yeah
hey as the guy said old habits die yes
they do
okay well it just makes me wonder no way
that's a too dark of a sex joke that's
what happens when you repress textures
do I make it real funny I was like won't
we get me that you cannot open up blood
gay well you ate if it's about a robot
you can't say that I was gonna say yeah
it's real dark man all right it's
probably better that you probably ins
it's usually not a form of you read
people appreciate hey new to channel mmm
dance I burped that cyber channel yeast
that's his channel about games
I do reviews and stuff he likes games
mmm Twitter Instagram Facebook that
Seibert guy can't find stop shot right
guy
go ahead of poo teacher thank you come
on done you can subscribe today to the
real rejects um be the hero that you
want to be but not the one you deserve
to be then my words alone for your
estimate don't be the hero that you want
to be happy therapy goodbye